This episode of Real Engineering is brought
to you by Skillshare.
Home to 15,000 classes that could teach you
a new life skill.
The first 500 people to sign up with the link
in the description will get a 2 month free
trial.
In August 2017, the Democratic People's Republic
of Korea, in it’s most provocative move
to date, tested a long range intercontinental
ballistic missiles, which flew directly over
the Japanese Northern Island of Hokkaido and
set sirens wailing.
This is just the latest in North Korean missile
test, with the previous month's test proving
the North Korean dictatorship had the capability
of reaching American soil.
The engineers of North Korea have overcome
many obstacles to get to this point, but just
achieving the necessary range is, thankfully,
half the battle.
Today we are going to investigate the history
behind these long range weapons and why they
are so difficult to engineer.
An Intercontinental ballistic missile, or
ICBM, is a missile that follows a ballistic
trajectory.
Quite simply, the path it follows is the same
as that of a thrown or propelled projectile
would take under the act of gravity.
Think of it as a projectile that is thrown
extraordinarily fast and high by a relatively
brief, yet powerful, rocket engine.
Like many weapons of mass destruction, the
Nazis were some of the first to theorize an
ICBM.
“Projekt Amerika”, led by Wernher von
Braun, was a code name for a weapon being
developed that could be used against New York
and other American cities during WWII.
Just as the V2, which was the world’s first
long-range ballistic missile, had been used
to wreak havoc on London.
Luckily the war ended before it was fully
developed.
but many of these same engineers were drafted
by the US and USSR after WWII to help design
their first rockets, and many of these design
philosophies laid the groundwork for what
we see today.
These early ICBM designs were essentially
upgraded versions of the V2 bombs.
The V2 was redesigned to include wings and
dubbed the A9.
This would sit on top of the huge first stage,
dubbed the A10, which would boost the V2 from
it’s original range of 300 kilometres, which
was enough to reach London from the Netherlands,
to 5000 km, enough to reach the American eastern
seaboard from Ireland.
The German engineers aimed the V2 simply by
setting a compass heading before launch, which
allowed the internal guidance system consisting
of gyroscopes to keep the rocket on course
while the rockets were firing.
Gyroscopes allow a missile to measure its
deviation from initial flight trajectories.
Spinning masses, like a gyroscope, want to
maintain the direction their axis of rotation
is pointing.
So if we set the axis of rotation in the direction
of desired travel, and mount the gyroscope
in a frame that does not transfer the missiles
rotation to the gyro, the missile can measure
that change in rotation and correct it’s
flight with control fins.
The German’s controlled the range by simply
adjusting the amount of fuel in the rocket,
using a slide rule to calculate the fuel needed
for a given trajectory.
Although this was incredibly advanced technology
for the time, the V2s were still notoriously
inaccurate, because it relied completely on
initial calculations on the ground and had
no way of correcting for unexpected deviations.
But London was a big target, and the Netherlands
weren’t that far away, and the Germans certainly
did not care who the bombs killed.
To be effective against a target much further
away would require a finer tuned guidance
system, which the Germans did not have.
So, incredibly, these early ICBMs were planned
to be manned.
After blasting off from Europe, exiting earth’s
atmosphere, separating the first stage, reaching
a max speed 10 times greater than the speed
of sound, the second stage would come hurtling
back through into the atmosphere, where it
would glide to reach it’s final target.
If they hadn’t already died from the heat
of re-entry the pilot would then set their
final trajectory using radio guidance from
surfaced German submarines and eject.
Only to be promptly killed by the force of
impact of air hitting his head and chest.
This was the German’s kamikaze strategy.
In an era before onboard computers and GPS
existed, developing a guidance systems was
half the battle.
Modern rockets use a combination of that gyroscope
based inertial guidance, satellite positioning
and terrain mapping, which uses altitude maps
of the route to the target to guide the missile.
You may wonder why the Germans put so much
effort into creating space age weapons, only
to equip them with bombs with less power than
those they could drop from planes.
Well this is arguably the hardest part of
the equation.
The longer the range and the heavier the load,
the more complex the rocket.
Just adding a first stage adds a significant
amount of complexity and cost to the design.
Adding a massive bomb was simply not feasible
and that’s just an issue of size and weight.
The German’s were limited with the type
of bomb they could use for another reason.
This is a size comparison between the V2 rockets
and the two nuclear bombs dropped on Japan.
Sizewise, it’s not inconceivable that these
bombs could have been integrated into the
V2, but Fat man and little boy weighed 4.6
tonnes and 4.4 tonnes respectively, so weight
would have been a huge issue.
The V2’s warhead consisted of a 1 tonne
amatol bomb, which is a TNT based explosive.
TNT’s primary advantage is its high activation
energy.
Meaning it would not easily detonate from
a sudden impact shock or from heat.
Even if small - lightweight nuclear bombs
existed at the time, neither America or Germany
had the technology required to launch them
with a missile, because of the intense heat
associated with re-entry of ICBMs would destroy
the warhead before it ever got close to the
target.
Re-entry vehicles typically used a combination
of blunt body design, ablative materials,
heat sinks and insulating materials.
Blunt body design allows the re-entry vehicle
to create a bow shock wave in front of the
vehicle that keeps the super heated plasma
a little further from vehicles surface, with
an insulating boundary layer of air in between.
Ablative materials, like the single use Gemini
heat shield,, burn or melt and then detach
from the vehicle carrying some of that super
heated plasma away and heat sinks use conductive
and heat resistant materials like Beryllium
to spread some of that heat and allow it to
be radiated away.
The Discovery Space Shuttle used reusable
and replaceable thermal tiles and blankets,
while the nose cone was a carbon-carbon composite
which acted as a heat sink.
But all of these things have one thing in
common.
They add bulk and mass to the design once
again.
Simply put, designing a rocket capable of
launching out earth's atmosphere is arguably
the easiest and most well documented part
of building an ICBM.
Miniaturising nuclear bombs capable of withstanding
the journey and creating a guidance system
accurate enough to hit the target is a whole
other challenge.
We know North Korea is struggling with this
part of their missile program, as the re-entry
of their July launch was caught on CCTV, showing
the missile burning up and disintegrating
before landing in the sea off the coast of
Japan and their recent test had a similar
fate.
So even if North Korea have a miniaturized
Nuclear bomb, it’s unlikely it would survive
the journey and when it comes to guidance,
North Korth do not have their own positioning
satellites, and it’s unlikely that China
have granted them access to their high accuracy
military positioning system.
For now North Korea don’t pose much of a
threat to America, but if they did somehow
develop an ICBM capable of carrying nuclear
weapons, despite the heavy embargoes on the
country, the world has moved on since the
days of V2 bombardment of defenceless London.
There are countermeasures and we will explore
them in the next video.
But if you want to watch something right now
and learn something new, I suggest you check
out
Skillshare.com, where you can find thousands
of different classes in a whole range of subjects.
Name a creative skill and they probably have
a class to teach you how to use it.
I have been trying to up my photography game
lately and have been finding their photography
classes incredibly useful.
These days you can teach yourself pretty much
any skill online and Skillshare is a fantastic
place to do it.
With professional and understandable classes,
that follow a clear learning curve.
You could even learn the skills to start a
new business like I did for this channel,
through courses for animation and editing.
A Premium Membership begins around $10 a month
for unlimited access to all courses, but the
first 500 people to sign up with this link
will get a 2 month free trial.
In those 2 months you could easily learn the
skills you need to start a new hobby or business,
just like I did with this channel.
So ask yourself right now.
What skill have you been putting off learning.
What project have you been dreaming of completing,
but you aren’t sure if you have the skills
to do it.
Why not start right now and sign up to Skillshare
using the link below.
You have nothing to lose and a valuable life
skill to gain.
As usual, thanks you for watching and thank
you to all my patreon supporters for helping
this channel exist.
If you would like to see more from me the
links for my social media accounts are in
the description and don’t forget to check
out the latest episode of my Podcast with
Sam from Wendover Productions.